IT'S TIME FOR OUR NEXT GAME.
PHOTOBOMBS: CREEPY OR CUTE?
THIS IS ONE OF MY FAVORITES.
AND IF YOU HAVEN'T SEEN IT,
IT WILL SOON BE ONE OF YOUR
FAVORITES. PHOTOBOMBS CAN GO
ONE OF TWO WAYS: THEY CAN GO
CREEPY OR CUTE.
WELL I GUESS THEY CAN GO CREEPY,
CUTE OR KEANU.
"CAN ONE OF YOU NINJA TURTLES
GIVE ME A RIDE?"
I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU A
PHOTOBOMB THAT, UNFORTUNATELY,
DOES NOT INCLUDE KEANU. AND FOR
250 POINTS, YOU ARE GOING TO
GUESS IF IT'S CREEPY OR CUTE.
FIRST ONE.
THESE FUN SUMMER LADIES.
WHAT IS BACK THERE? IT'S
PROBABLY GREAT. JADE.
>> I THINK IT'S DEFINITELY
CREEPY.
>> Chris: LET'S FIND OUT.
>> NO PANTS?
Chris: YA, IT IS.
>> IT WAS CREEPY.
>> HE'S ACTUALLY MARRIED TO ALL
OF THOSE WOMEN.
>> Chris: NEXT ONE.
THIS STERN SCULPTURE, CREEPY OR
CUTE?
>> GOT TO BE CREEPY. HE'S
SITTING IN A SITTING POSITION.
I'M NERVOUS WHERE THIS IS GOING.
>> CUTE.
Chris: LET'S SEE.
OH.
>> WAIT A MINUTE.
>> IT'S BOTH.
>> THAT'S CREEPY.
Chris: WHY IS IT CREEPY? BECAUSE
THEY'RE TWO BOY RABBITS?
>> IT'S JUST LOVE.
Chris: WHAT'S WRONG WITH YOU?
WHAT'S WRONG WITH GAY RABBITS?
WHY DO YOU HATE GAY RABBITS?
>> THIS IS AMERICA.
>> I WAS LOOKING AT THE STATUE.
>> LEAVE HER ALONE.
Chris: ASHLEY, THIS IS
BEAUTIFUL.
>> IT'S BEAUTIFUL, YOU'RE RIGHT.
>> THAT CHICKEN IS SO LONELY IN
THE BACKGROUND.
>> I DIDN'T SEE THE CHICKEN.
Chris: I DIDN'T SEE THE
CHICKEN.
AMAZING.
>> HE KEEPS TURNING UP HIS NOSE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Chris: ALRIGHT.
NEXT ONE.
THIS PROM COUPLE.
CREEPY OR CUTE?
>> THIS HAS TO BE A CREEPY OLD
DAD OR SOMETHING.
>> Chris: SOMETHING?
>> A MIRROR.
Chris: THESE TWO KIDS TOGETHER
READY FOR THEIR FIRST DATE.
>> I'M GOING CREEPY.
Chris: WHAT COULD BE WEIRD
ABOUT THIS? OH, YES.
>> CREEPY.
>> BECAUSE LOSING YOUR VIRGINITY
IS KIND OF LIKE GOING TO WAR.
[LAUGHING]
>> Chris: I CAN'T TELL WHO HE'S
RELATED TO.
I CAN'T TELL IF IT'S --
>> THE TWO ON THE ENDS ARE
TOGETHER?
[LAUGHING]
>> HE HAS BEEN HIRED FOR THE
NIGHT.
>> Chris: THIS MOM AND TOT:
CREEPY OR CUTE?
>> THIS IS GOING TO BE REALLY
CREEPY I FEEL IT.
THE BABY FEELS IT.
>> Chris: I THINK BOTH.
>> OH.
LOOK AT THAT SIDE BOOB.
LOOK AT THE SIDE BOOB!
OH!
>> WE SHOULD PUT SIDE BOOB IN
PICTURE.
>> SIDE BOOB OR SIDE HANDLE.
>> SIDE HANDLE.
WHAT'S HE HAVING? A MARGARITA?
>> SOMETHING BITTER, I'M SURE.